ces jours de formation pour des
policiers de l'agglomération de
longueuil et de richelieu-saint-laurent
le sujet du jour
comment mieux prévenir les cas de
féminicide lors d'interventions
policières qui ont lieu avant un drame
pour ceux qui portent l'uniforme
remettre en question les méthodes de
travail auprès des femmes est essentiel
c'est un défi pour un policier de
détecter qu'est ce qui se passe qu'elle
est la dynamique qu'est ce que je vois
est ce que c'est de la violence
conjugale et danse interclubs du
contrôle coercitif ça ne laisse aucune
marque
c'est ce contrôle psychologique c'est de
la violence verbale c'est des gestes à
répétition qui sont sur cette formation
arrive à un bon moment
les prochains mois qui seront marquées
par le déconfinement progressive du
québec laisse craindre une hausse de
signalements de violences conjugales le
dune mardi tout de suite d'emblée voulez
vous porter plainte
les voilà devant un juge peut être
plutôt lui demander qu'est ce qui vous
fait pas quelles sont vos craintes
est-ce que vous avez pas pour vos
enfants pour votre sécurité et ça vient
tout changer car l'élément de confiance
et peut-être plus facile à donner à ce
moment là le but de cette formation
mieux aider les femmes mais on rappelle
aux policiers qu'il existe également des
ressources pour les hommes violents qui
sont prêts à changer leurs comportements
à la hausse par 60 % de notre clientèle
à en bottes 40 ans une grosse partie en
18 et 25 ans pour moi c'est très positif
ça veut dire que le message social qu'on
tolère plus la violence a fonctionné ça
veut dire que ces jeunes hommes là
viennent nous consulter avant que la
dynamique soit ancrée pour moi c'est une
très bonne nouvelle
au cours des prochains mois cette
formation en matière de violence
conjugale sera offerte à d'autres
policiers en montérégie ici pascal
robidas radio-canada à longueuil